giants in san francisco have an area
for people who are allergic to peanuts
get out of here it's called puto cliff
right
tell the right field line
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god hi
with me george lopez
let's do the show
directly right phelps
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george
george lopez oh my god omg omg
thanks for our sponsor medterra
they craft trusted effective and
accessible cbd products that support
deeper sleep relaxation and relief
that's right go to medterra and it's
m-e-d-t-e-r-r-a-dot-com
slash
omg hi and enter the code omg h i
at checkout for 30 off
and free shipping with your first order
of medterra
guys it's all about confidence when it's
time for sex am i right
sometimes
stress can affect your performance and
ruin the fun
blue chew
comes to the rescue try bluetooth free
when you use our promo code omg hi at
checkout and just pay five dollars
shipping that's bluetooth.com promo code
omghi to receive your first month free
imagine
that wessel's come your way for just
five dollars shipping
hey hey i'm in i'm incurable
makes you doable get a blue chew
and then
and the doors to panocha town open wide
up
a lot of latinos in chicago
yeah they do i found them they they they
uh
they do well out there man they got
their own
individual uh um neighborhood
i went over i took mayan uh to go eat
over there on uh pilsner i think maybe
street
and uh
we had some
gardener salad with some french fries
flank cute steak with with
with fries like in and out fries oh bad
come on
hey while we're on chicago let me give
it a shot when i went back there a
couple of weeks ago to do that
fundraiser help them with a fundraiser
back there yeah uh that was there to
help out wounded veterans
and to assist surviving family members
of cops killed in the line of duty
and these guys don't care where the cops
are killed i just want to say that they
sent two cops out here just a couple
weeks ago for the two officers from
albany that were murdered they were
killed in the line of duty that was uh
officer
paredes and santana
that were killed in the line of duty and
chicago set
two guys
rick uh
caballero the the guy that heads up the
organization
sent him out here just to be there at
the funeral just to give the family some
money so everything they're doing back
there's a great job man that's
everything in the bottom
yeah
and the guys come out here they take
their own time off they're on duty
they're regular cop working cops
they send two sergeants out here they
take their own time
uh the organization fronts their their
fees to fly them out but what a great
job and they do it for all over the
united states another shout out
to chicago pd
uh you know being that i've been away
for
a few months
i'm not familiar with uh with what
happened with those two officers what
hap what happened
it was uh on june 18th they responded to
a call
of a man with a knife and when they got
there it was an ambush the guy was
inside he was he was on probation he
should have been in custody uh but under
the current regime the way it was he was
out
and he was waiting for him they got
there and he opened up with a gun just
as they got there
and uh
so he got killed
but most importantly he killed two
working cops that grew up in armani all
they wanted to be were money cops
so they could give back to their
community
and they they died in the line of duty
and who was that guy that shot him like
like was he in a house or was he in an
apartment or he was he was in a hotel
room
and when they got to the hotel when they
got to the place he just opened up the
door and
started lighting them up
and uh
these guys but the whole community the
city to armani did a great job they they
came together they've got a
great association there uh with their
cops and and the way they work with
their community and these guys truly
grew up there
and wanted to be where they were
and it just shows you know when
everybody's talking about you know
defunding police these guys were willing
to put their lives on the line for the
people they serve
and that's what they did
uh
you know uh
i mean
there's been so much
um
violence over the last
few years so many unnecessary
deaths police officers included you know
anybody that
dies in a line of duty or
or anybody really uh it's such a
um
what do they say i mean
you know there isn't a better way
that
we found to police it didn't it doesn't
work
um
private i mean it's just i don't know
man i mean i don't know what the answer
is you know they're they're
they don't have an answer you know
there's for anybody to want to be in law
enforcement
especially the way the times are it's
just
i don't know man i mean it it's such a
huge huge
um
thing you know and and uh um
i think the the the unfortunate
uh
uh of the tragedy that involves police
officers
definitely
uh would gather more attention than
a couple of police officers losing their
their lives in the line of duty and
being from a neighborhood that they
wanted to patrol not all
you know police officers and not all
police departments and not all
um
officers are
i don't think they're against their
community man it's it
it's just such a
[ __ ] of
of what
we've become as a society
yeah
it is
they're still the ones that you call
but
it's just an
unimaginable position to be
to be in
it is it it is and you could see
by by talking about
those guys i just been
uh
with guys from armani police department
at the 100 year anniversary of homicide
bureau
and and in fact i was sitting at the
right table the right place
uh they announced pick up your plate on
your table
and if there's a coin underneath
and i just happened to be sitting at the
table there was that coin it was a
challenge coin from the city of romani
and then they gave me a nice bottle of
scotch and everybody want to take
pictures it's really nice and then to
see these guys it really
as you can see it affected me
uh emotionally
you know what these kids do
and people just don't understand it
now they're good now let's talk about
something [ __ ] funny let's get it
rolling brook
well you know uh
let's talk about
i mean listen it's been it's been 42
years
since the all-star game has been in los
angeles yes
um
i think it was supposed to be here in 20
and then we had the pandemic
and in that uh
and in that time of us growing up
the dodgers were owned by a family
alex the the uh
o'malley's
right
so
you know
the dodgers are not without their
uh
uh that's that you know
uh
i don't know what to say they're not
without their issues but um
uh
going to
going to the games when fox i didn't go
when
they were sold to fox or frank mccord i
think that guy frank mccord
i didn't go to the i didn't go to the
games for a long time
and it was around that time that that
guy was the owner
and i think that
he may even still own the parking
lot he does he just got he he's trying
to get his wessel in there he wants to
put a tram overhead tram
i think from the train station up to
so he still has it he still has his hand
in there and and i was a seasoned ticket
holder when he took over
and
because he kept driving the prices up
and i just couldn't afford it i you know
i just couldn't afford it anymore i was
paying
uh
i had the ticket so long and then i had
my last ticket for right behind home
plate aisle uh four
you know they were great seats row r
and when i started with them they were
50 bucks a piece and they went 75 bucks
a piece for a while and then
we got notified they're going to go to
125 bucks a piece i mean with four guys
every time you got four seats
i mean i'm not j paul getty i'm not i'm
not jordan lopez i ain't got that kind
of money so i said hey we tried a kid i
gave him up only to find out that he was
borrowing money
that's why we weren't getting any
players he was borrowing money
from the dodgers for his own personal
use to buy more property
yeah and and so i said john i can't i
can't do that uh it's definitely um
you know it's almost like uh the royal
family i think you know if you're a
baseball fan in los angeles yeah it
would be like following buckingham
palace i mean just to examine the
stadium
change in the way that uh i mean i
remember when
chingazos were rare at at dodger stadium
and they sold schlitz beer and they sold
32 ounce [ __ ] beers
and the dudes would stack their [ __ ]
beers
on top in empty cups
the more the more they drank and they
[ __ ] have
stacks of beers
and
but
there wasn't really violence at dodgers
no the only thing that went up it was
printed at the times at one time during
the o'malley regime
when fernando mania took over
chp announced they made more drunk
driving arrests from
fernando pitts than any other time in
the game yeah so
the latinos went out for him and
unfortunately they drank too much it was
a great time
you know uh
i went to uh myself for now to pitch a
lot a lot
uh
opening day when he shut out the
when he won the first night then jerry
royce was sick and then he pitched and
then we were all about also we we took a
day off work and by the time we got
out of the parking lot we had sobered up
we were [ __ ] in the in the line
[Laughter]
two hours trying to get down to a legion
park and by the time you got there
you're like already coherent again you
know because you're not going anywhere
uh and uh just the maybe the biggest
parking lot of any
major league stadium
or maybe any stadium i mean that parking
lot is it's big
it's big and then will call was all the
way down that they don't even know what
will call was back then yeah uh
and uh
you know all of the you know should
fernando's
number be retired yes yes should
fernando be in the hall of fame
undoubtedly sure should
um there be a campaign from the dodgers
yes is there
no
so
um i mean he's still there he's an
announcer for spanish um language you
know for him and jaime harina i think
he's still there or maybe i'm a jaime
just retired he just retired i mean to
have been scully and jaime harin for 50
years plus in los angeles and listen to
them growing up
is
you know there's always been great at
ernie hartwell in detroit and then the
guy all those guys are back east but we
had
uh oh harry carey yeah i mean and we had
uh
those guys forever
so
um i mean i would like to see the
dodgers be a little better to fernando
than they've been
um i don't think they really i don't
think they're really even
uh retiring any numbers anymore nor do i
feel like they are
um
they don't have old-timers game anymore
no um
this week is uh all-star week in los
angeles i got invited to play in the uh
game
the the hollywood stars game maybe but i
yeah i can't do it because i'm still
going to be here but i wanted to i
played in
2004 i loved it the idea of sitting in
the leftover pavilion and rightful
pavilion sometimes
and then seeing willie davidson
centerfield and jimmy nguyen and mike
marshall and
dusky baker
willie crawford
greg lozinski maddox and the phillies
all the great outfielders that i got to
see sure and to be
playing outfit i played center field
uh caught a ball hit the center field
awesome it was the last year they did
baseball now it's softball
um
but
the idea that
you can't get a dodger dog at dodger
stadium anymore
because
they couldn't get the name
they couldn't work out the
deal with
with farmer john i think farmer john's
even closing armor john is closing down
they're moving out of uh vernon
because they're uh i want to say i want
to say the the asians bottom up
yeah i mean
i mean man
is i mean i'm sure they're things that
are better than the dodger dog but
listen to this i don't know if you
followed the news lately right now the
big controversy is the concession
workers
they've announced they may go on strike
for the all-star game well that's where
i'm going ain't that that's where i'm
going oh i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm just
taking that i'm taking you know what you
[ __ ] feel an hour i gotta [ __ ]
want to just put it in and [ __ ] take
it out we'll be done
i'm drinking for both of us that you're
not drinking today man
i i got [ __ ] mosquitoes in here i got
to try to find and kill so far i've only
i'm only killing myself
with the spray that i'm using
but
um
it's bad in this room
oh now you sound like my wife
man
they've been i've been getting [ __ ]
bit every night
i'm ready to start lighting [ __ ]
napkins on fire
my drama is to do that [ __ ] those are
[ __ ]
lit [ __ ] uh
uh brownies under the under the uh uh a
sink all the [ __ ] cucarachas would
run out
fireworks
fireworks when you're dealing with uh
insects
they don't like fire
and you could just see the coconuts
their antennas you know just melt mel
there you go [ __ ] so so
um
whatever the concessions were i remember
they used to say arthur i thought
everybody's
when i was a kid i thought everybody
okay everybody is everybody's name
arthur i thought everybody's name was
arthur
and arthur was the company
i don't even remember all this [ __ ]
that's that that's you know
but but uh
i don't know what they have at
for hot dogs now i haven't been um
but i think you can buy
maybe you can buy a dodger dog and put
it together yourself somewhere in l.a
[ __ ] they're selling dodger dog i go to
uh stator brothers yeah they're selling
wieners and right in their in their meat
section loose and their original farmer
john dodger's dog that's what they call
them dodger dog we'll go over there and
then you'll eat one and you'll run
around like a uniform and then i'll run
around to make it look like [ __ ]
watching facebook
i look like tommy lasorda running around
but but uh
when that when the dodgers had those
wheels that you would turn
and the onions would come out oh yeah
yeah yeah
and then the wheel that you would turn
and relish would come out
and then they had the big tubs of
mustard
and ketchup and oh don't tell me you put
ketchup on your hot dog brother no i
don't [ __ ] that oh
but
when they took that away
and then you started getting like what
you get now a couple of packs of of
ketchup
a couple of packs of mustard
uh a [ __ ] little
chingadera of one of these of uh of
onions
yeah
and
i
i don't know i don't know where where
where that stadium is going you know
um but the concession people
striking
i'm not i'm not four strikes but i can
see
them with the purpose of striking
especially i thought that due to roger
the peanut guy
he's still there and then they they just
announced last week they stopped him
from throwing the peanuts
that guy had it going for years he's
done it like for 48 years already
and why and why don't they want roger
thrown peanuts
they didn't say
there was no statement as to why he just
said they told me to stop
and and the dodgers didn't have a
statement as to why
because somebody's going to get hurt
i am
because somebody has a peanut allergy
i think so
giants in san francisco have an area
for people who are allergic to peanuts
get out of here it's called puto cliff
right
down the right field line
i mean what are we going to do man you
can't go to a game
because somebody might be allergic to
peanuts near you
and then you're cracking them and you
put them on the ground and sure yeah
it's airborne it can get in there
and then
nobody can touch
the spoon the same spoon that you used
to get relish with the
the crank
listen man
if anybody that used those things past
the fifth inning is still alive
you go to the bathroom and wash your
hands that was a [ __ ] crack
i mean just
listen man i'm not sure if if being
hygienically safe is the best way to
live healthy i think you have to have
some [ __ ]
on you in order to make your
your body work
your body
for [ __ ] to
to to to to fight off things
that's it
you know you're trying to take a [ __ ]
bath you got your bath the old fashioned
way you can't put any parel on your
webble thing hey it dries it up
it it dries them up
i mean they're
like the little dude says that come
wrapped up individually
uh uh uh
wexler is what they call uh
but but uh
yeah man i i think you know
um when you used to go to baseball games
or go to sporting events
you didn't see
the business part of it you saw the game
yes
um and i think now with
i mean i think the dodger
concession people
uh
i don't know what they're asking for but
i'm gonna say they probably deserve it
because there's never been there's been
player
uh strikes
uh they shut down baseball for half a
year
they shut down hockey
i think they did it with football ever
play some players but
the people that work at the stadium i
would probably say that
maybe they're not taken care of as
properly as they should
maybe it's it's their time and you know
who's going to replace them with other
latinos no
yeah what would they
and then you would see the same ushers
and you would say the same people and
they became almost like they knew where
you sat i mean exactly you were friends
i'd see them thinking they knew you it
was all friends i could go
when i had the before i had my last ones
i had some down first baseline
i was in row w then
and i could get up after the last pitch
of the inning
go order me four beers go to the head
pick them up on the way back and still
get back before the next inning started
because we were friends with everybody
everybody knew each other
matter of fact one time we were right
under the overhang on the first bayside
it started drizzling so everybody
started coming out of the front going
back and yeah there was a doctor that
owned four seats right in front of us
and he's sitting there and he's not
there that day he's four seats were
bringing he didn't show the game
two guys came up and they're looking and
said come on sit here no no man these
aren't overseas what if they come by
says just shut up sit down take a seat
and so they sit down
and
half inning later two guys come up and
they pulled out their tickets excuse me
you're sitting in our seats and i said
oh we're sorry we just want to get out
of the rain okay here you go they got up
and they walked away and this guy sit
down he said see i told you it'd work
they weren't their seats either ah those
[ __ ]
oh my god your story shoes awesome
yeah everybody that's sitting in
someone's seat has been latino man and
you
you
you know because you see somebody
walking down you're like all right get
ready and it wasn't them wasn't them
wasn't them but yeah everybody
everybody's had snuck in down uh stuck
down to get uh in a better and a better
place
i remember they were thinking what time
they were taking out some
uh a fan that was all bubbles so he was
drunk and he was causing trouble so
they're taking him out and all the crowd
is around him
hey take come on get them out of here
here comes security and they're driving
they handcuff them and they're taking
them out
and some of the chicanos are saying no
no they're on cutbacks right now they're
not going to let them in the jail leave
them here keep them here screaming all
right it's a crazy place i love it i
love it i i i have not had one bad
experience
in dodger station i hope that whatever
it is because i mean if you're gonna
strike
this is the week to do it
i mean all the attention um sure
is is is on
on dodger stadium and um
you know the the
the subtlety of the
remodeling that they've done
um
[Music]
you know they've done a lot of
remodeling man they've been good it's
good a couple of years ago a handful of
years ago they
removed the first the field level and
then worked on the locker rooms
and worked on that stuff underneath
and
i went into the visitors locker room
and you see the modern day
locker room which is amazing
and then in the corner they had kept
some of the old visitors locker there
and it was like if um
it was like if you were at farmer john
killing pigs like that the [ __ ] skull
was little
yeah i had that chicken wire kind of
type you know and just
really nothing man it's amazing to think
what
the athletes used to do
and never complained
that the locker room
wasn't the way it is now with reclining
chairs and big screen tvs
and opulence and state of the art
i mean uh at in the at in every stadium
because i've seen the dodgers do it that
a
dodger who's playing who's not maybe not
necessarily up in that inning
will go down that hall and then there's
a room that has a computer
and then you're in there with a coach
and you can go over what
that guy has thrown you
from
seasons past or from games past
so the guy's playing in the game
but he's not setting the dugout but he's
in that room
looking at
pictures from a picture that's out there
pitching from other games i mean that
yeah when i was in high school we had a
guy named mike robinson a white dude
that came from kennedy high school and
that dude
had a book like he would say who's
pitching and he would look and he'd take
out his book
and he had a pen
and he had a book of
all the pictures that he faced
in high school what they threw him and
what he what he hit i mean [ __ ]
amazing
sure that a high school player had that
medterra was founded by group friends
passionate about bringing cbd to those
who love it most if you haven't heard of
cbd it can promote relaxation sleep and
a sleuth of other benefits
topicals like hemp infused
manuka cream
and on-the-go pain relief roll-on help
you
balance your skin and body and mind
tasty sweets like their full spectrum
deep sleep gummies support your journey
in finding deep
restorative sleep that leads to a
rejuvenated day modern life is so busy
that we often put your recovery at rest
last because there just isn't enough
time uh medterra has designed high
quality accessible and easy to
incorporate wellness solutions
like their manuka cream and pain relief
roll on to support daily
wellness it's not being looked at even
like you're a full-on marijuana anymore
this is all like medicine you know
before they believe
now now everybody's doing it because
it's medicine full spectrum
deep sleep gummies are a sweet and
simple way to fall asleep faster stay
asleep longer and wake up feeling
refreshed and who knows you might wake
up with ho ho ho
knock out two for one
and then go back to sleep it's funny man
because uh you know we have stigmas of
what
cbd and all those things are and i think
that
in growing up the way that we grew up
we were more about the pill you know
like hey did the doctor give you some
pills you take your pills and do all
that but pills we found out that
are not the best now you know going back
to the way that the the the
way the earth provides you know and i
think um
sleeping with those cbds and using
roll-ons and all that stuff that they
use for wellness i mean i think you you
feel it though right when you use stuff
like that you you benefit from that
don't you
i sure do
i sure do
yeah and i don't wake up like i do after
i've been drinking wine all night that's
right you see so it's all overall all
around
uh better our products are third party
tested so it's like two do's go hey give
that dude something
non-gmo contains organic ingredients and
grain free i wish my grandma was still
alive i could probably loading her up
with this stuff
i should
[Laughter]
oh my god hi listeners get 30 off and
free shipping on their order to medterra
go to medterra.com
omgh and enter the code
omghi at checkout that's medterra
dot that's medterra
you know the thing that's messed up is
so many words in our life that we use
around them
hi
and enter the code omg hi
at checkout and receive 30 off
and free shipping sleep 30 better get 30
percent off and be 30 better prepared to
take on the new day
bluetooth is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
chewable form and at a fraction of the
cost
blue chews tablets help men achieve
harder stronger erection men combat all
forms of ed
because bluetooth is an online
prescription service there are no visits
to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations
and no waiting in line at the pharmacy
and it ships right to your door in a
discreet
patch
the process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days the best part
is that it's all done online bluetooth
licensed medical providers work with you
to find the right ingredient and
strength for your prescription don't
like swallowing pills no problem here
blue chews tablets are
chewable just like the skin right under
your webbles
your cute tablets are made in the usa
and they prepare and ship direct so it's
cheaper than a pharmacy blue chewable
makes you doable try bluetooth free when
you use the promo code omg hi at
checkout and just pay five dollars
shipping that's bluetooth.com promo code
omghi to receive your first month free
and and my bad because i'm not george
lopez i don't have the memory that you
do
a few years ago
uh because the guy a friend of mine
he took care of the visitors locker room
that was his job he was in charge of it
he did everything got him food made
everything
and he was into this true crime stuff
like you yeah and so he he became
friends and he graduated from the same
high school that i went to
and so he wanted to give me a tour and
so he gave me a tour of the whole state
i got to go in the locker room with all
the guys it was awesome
but then he said
you know what bring your kid back here
he's my grandson
i want to say he was 16 years old then
17 years old he says bring him back here
the last day
it was the last game was this was when
the dodgers
uh jumped in the swimming pool over in
arizona
okay so they clinched the west they came
back here for their last series it was
against the rockies
and the first baseman that was going to
be he's going to be in the hall of fame
i just his name slips me and i apologize
to him
he was on a team
and
that guy had my grandson put him in a
rockies uniform and let him be the bad
boy for the day and he went out there he
took pictures with the guys he says it
was the best day of his life he's now 22
and he still remembers the catcher who
was a latino
was on getting ready to go out in the on
deck circle my grandson's in the well
the latino hit him he grounded out the
first time up he went out there this
time he hit my grandson in the head with
a bat
intentionally just tapped him yeah went
out there he got a base hit
come back next time up he says hey work
the first time bam hit him again
and my grandson just had the time of his
life out there
yeah that day it was good stuff
i think that you know uh
in being a baseball family you know uh
you you don't want to see it uh
um
tainted by
by
by big money or by not treating the
people that
really i mean we're in a time now where
you're trying to take things away from
people not give them things
so you know all of the concession
workers and all of the people that are
there early
and stay late and somebody's got to
clean that [ __ ] up
and and
i think you know it's all about the
bottom line man
in a business run by billionaires that
the people that provide for your fans
and for your players
should be
um
taken care of and saying that
we don't take care of teachers why
anybody would want to be a teacher i'd
rather
be [ __ ] roger than penis at dodger
stadium to be a teacher because
they don't make any money they never
have
they look everything
for everything
for everything
i've had to uh
i've had to see teachers buy
pencils and paper
and balls and
things for their class out of their own
pocket sure
and
i thought that um
money for the lottery was going to go to
to
help uh
help the schools
it hasn't
so
i i've seen the same thing so
between
teachers
you know everything we do in life today
as adults we owe the teachers
they started us out and when i was
growing up
you screwed up in school
parents beat the [ __ ] out of me
and you know it's my fault don't be
blaming those teachers coming on i know
and today
people are quick to blame the teachers
it's their fault
you know and and then it goes into from
the teachers and the adult the cops and
and you know what don't blame us for
what you couldn't control
you know when you were when he was a kid
you know you had the
ability to train them to teach them and
you didn't and now you blame somebody
else for their faults
it's and they're underpaid they don't
get enough money
their supplies they take nothing but
grief
god bless them them and nurses
i love them
what about those guys that uh the the
i mean that's touchy what about the the
cop at park at parkland in florida that
waited outside and didn't go in there
like what's the duty of the
of the office you know the the latest
the latest biggest one
is the one that was where all those kids
died the cops waited outside
and the chief of police was taken the
chief and school police wherever he gave
the order is taking a bunch of [ __ ]
uh
you know i i'm not one to kick a man
when he's down but as he should
uh i still stay very close in tune and
in touch
with local law enforcement
and one of my partners that comes by
your local station where i live you come
by and visit
and i said hey what about this you know
because that's that's not wrong
we are trained here
here and rest assured
just like those cops have died from
armani
if
it's an active shooter we are trying to
go in now
don't wait for backup don't do [ __ ] you
go in there now
you
your family may miss you
that's what you've been trained for
you're there for others
and
i i'm sorry the guy that said don't go
in there wait for backup he's wrong he's
just
he's just wrong
and there were other cops that wanted to
go in there one guy defied the orders
uh i understand he fight and went in on
his own
and finally broke into the stuff but it
it it's terrible it's tragic
uh never should have happened
never should have happened they should
have stopped that guy
a cop may have lost his life
but we would have saved others
and and uh
don't they lock the door aren't they
supposed to lock the doors when kids
like
you know
i mean should have been around school
forever but i think that they would lock
most of the doors around the school so
you had to go into one one way
yeah
i don't know what school policies are
now
and since that incident you know i've
seen on the internet or other schools
especially back in texas
you know where they're allowing teachers
to pack a gun
you know now people would sit there and
say
well that's too dangerous there's kids
around what if somebody gets hurt well
what i want somebody packing a gun to
save my kids life
you know
yeah i would you know there ain't no
doubt about it
yes anything that's gonna save lives
is gonna help
tragically is somebody gonna lose their
life
you know maybe this guy isn't trained
well enough and he accidentally should
that could happen that that can but
i i'd much rather see him do have an
accident than let a guy go in there and
massacre 17 kids
a how uh
like if you look at it at at
you know people that have multiple guns
or ars and all that stuff police
police don't
they have a shock they have like a pump
shotgun right and a and uh not a glocker
they don't come out there with assault
weapons we now have
they do have shotguns they do have guns
that pump out you know not the real
bullets but rubber bullets they do have
ars
but they don't have them in all the cars
they may have the sergeant may have one
in his car
you know and i told uh because even when
i was working i had a i had a uh officer
involved shooting down in the city of
hawthorne
where the guy was pointing the gun and
there had to be at least 20 cops because
there's been a pursuit
he had been shooting up at the pointing
the gun up and
up at the helicopter
and
the guy went around the corner
and the helicopter said hey beware he's
out of his car he's around the corner
now and they all went up and the guy
turned around and pointed the gun at him
about 20 cops let him up
and
the
man in charge the commander
from my department
knew that i you know knew that i'm a
seasoned guy he wanted to finally says
man i'm just glad they didn't have an
ar-15 out here
you know 20 guys lit the guy up because
i'm just glad they didn't have an arv
and i said
he's lucky they didn't have a machine
gun right i said i don't have to wait
for depend on somebody else to shoot him
this guy's pointed a gun who do i trust
that guy may shoot me
and
he was trying to kill cops and so they
did what they had to do you know i i
don't care about safety right now you're
talking about life and when it's life
and death because i've been not only in
the streets i've been in combat
right you you can't panic you have to
react
the uh um
in the northridge i mean the uh shooting
of the bank of america north hollywood
the hollywood shootout yeah
those the police officers went to a gun
store to buy [ __ ] that they didn't have
because they were outgunned
they were yeah
and though and those
i mean i mean those bullets go through
they go through cars don't think that i
mean yeah they they go through cars
you know and if you look at that the way
it ended up
some of those officers at the end
god bless
lapd swat those guys some of them
weren't in uniform they were in street
clothes
they responded they attacked they didn't
have bests on they just knew what they
had to do they're trained they got out
there and they and they
put it put an ending to it but yeah you
do whatever you got to do and people
don't realize that and they only think
about that's why
unfortunately
uh the armani officers lost their life
it wasn't because they were
they didn't have the proper weaponry or
it was just a tragedy
but people it made local people realize
that yeah there is a need for law
enforcement who else is going to stop
this animal
who else was going to do anything when
people will run away from a gunfire cops
run into it right so they they deserve
to get what they want they're trained
and hopefully they'll survive
you know i i i i think some of those
guns have like red tips and stuff like
that i'm not sure if
you know
i'm not sure if if the way [ __ ] is now
that
they shouldn't even be selling any
[ __ ] guns to kids even anymore
i just don't see
i just don't see a reason why
i mean they had a situation where
police pull guns on a 12 year old kid
but it's like you know
i mean
it's all tragic but also
the temperatures is [ __ ] high for
that [ __ ] man
like you know kids that are 12 don't
look 12 i'm not defending anything but
but
when you're driving in a car and you see
or hear somebody and then you see
something you have to make the
decision immediately
um and i would just
if i was 12
or a kid
i don't think i'd be playing
with guns in public
it's it's up
it it truly is and and parents once
again it comes back to the parish you
gotta
you gotta control uh your kids
i know
i i know my compadre called me up one
day he was crying on the phone
because i was at home he was just
calling and see if i was all right a cop
in east l.a had just been just been
killed in the lineup he's just been shot
she's calling on my house he heard my
voice and he started crying
and he says i want you to know
i'd rather go visit you in prison than
have to go to your gravesite
and and that was very meaningful to me
because this was a tough dude from
he was a
he was a tough guy
yeah and i said it it's okay
you know hopefully you'll never have to
go visit me in prison
but it's a split second decision some of
these guys have to make
some can do it some panic and don't some
messed up i've been shot at as i
explained i've been shot at by cops on
duty
and that guy ended up getting fired god
fortunately the grace of god nobody got
hit
right but he was shooting at me
and so
he could never be a good he could never
be a cop again you know so he got fired
he went off into the sunset
but
nobody was hit
um they even tried to use like private
security firms that doesn't work either
because
they're more aggressive than the police
officers
you know they don't have the proper
training and they don't have the skills
up and the mental capability you know
they get angry they couldn't be a real
cop so then they got a security job
and sometimes they think that's
the real world and it isn't
and they're going to have problems right
now they have problem locally in la
with uh they just got a new city
councilwoman they got on the board she
wants to get rid of all lapd
you know and they want to socialize the
train you know the transients are using
the homeless or using the trains
and they're defecating on the trains or
sleeping on the trains so how do you get
on there want to use it as a mode of
transportation when you're just going to
work
you can't and they want to use
civilians
and and do you think these guys give
give two shits about somebody no they
don't
you know so they're just they're trying
to socialize everything and it just
ain't gonna work not right now none of
the current climate it's funny because
you know in the pandemic like nobody was
out
um
but then now we're seeing the result of
of the homeless people that are out
there the crime that's out there
and like we talked about before about
being safe you know about going to get
gas during the day or going to run your
errands during the day and not
doing them at night not going to get gas
at night not going to get gas after work
you know of picking the time that you
would be out there
and trying not to be out there at night
i think it's very dangerous i mean los
angeles is as dangerous as i think i've
ever
seen it be
just in the last couple of days
once again i don't know what news you're
getting but they had the former olympian
she was a black female athlete i forget
what sport she played in
uh but she was a black metal winner
and downtown
not
a volleyball volleyball player yeah okay
and not in the not a good
[Laughter]
she was in downtown l.a just got done
having lunch over there in the nice area
downtown
and some transit come up and for no
reason unprovoked didn't say [ __ ] just
came up and started beating her
and she's on the tv giving her side of
the story you know her eyes shut broke
and this broken net stitches
and just totally unprovoked
you know they got the guy in custody
but
you know
is it safe right here by where i live
yes couple of days ago
an asian couple
you know in broad daylight walking out
of the only 99 markets or some asian
market right here in rowland heights
him and his wife got jumped on beat the
[ __ ] and they stole his watch and i
vomitos
you know so and that was in broad
daylight 1 30 in the afternoon you ever
been to one of those markets right there
in alhambra el chinito markets no no you
go in there and buy a [ __ ] dolphin
that's all you anything in there
you could buy a [ __ ] hawk you could
buy a [ __ ] dolphin and a baby seal
whatever but we bought a cow dick that
[ __ ] thing
you're like hey if
if if any animal has a dick that big let
them keep it like [ __ ] it it's like hey
man
we're sorry to bother you sir hey little
stuff it mounted i mean
they sell [ __ ] that
they'll buy a [ __ ] uh uh uh
uh a lamb either a b-boy you know tie it
up already
just put this little thing over today
i'll be ready to ready to go for any
occasion but i mean they
and they have shampoo different
different
fragrances that you don't have in uh
in regular
america you know they they just have a
different
they're different products i don't know
where they get those products at but but
they get different smells than we do
i've been into one asian market right
here at my house i went in there once i
i haven't gone back in there because all
it smelled like was fish
yeah there was everywhere you went to
places you smelled the the fish order
and i i not that it turns me on but i
want to smell something other fish you
know in the market
yeah
it's uh
it's a crazy time man over here over
here too um
uh just i don't know man lawlessness you
know i think a little bit and i'm not
sure
if it's a government problem i think it
has to be dealt with on the city level
i don't think it could be done we wait
for the government to do anything i mean
it's got to be done
but if someone if someone sees something
happening
i would i would probably say it's better
not to get involved
yes
yes i i had to talk with my family last
night
because i was
because it happened locally they have
the local buzz on the internet so people
are watching this and it made the news
and saw the internet all over the place
and they said why didn't somebody help
this couple why didn't somebody jump in
there well they pistol whipped the poor
old people
now you see somebody pistol-whipping
somebody you're gonna want to jump in
there and say hey hey leave them alone
no no
you got to become a good witness
that's all you can do
because at this point it's not up to you
to put your life on the line for
somebody you don't know that's what cops
get paid for okay let's see what their
lives on the line let's say you come
home
and somebody's in your house
okay
and there and you know when you walk in
maybe you're walking from your garage
into your kitchen and you look around
and you're like okay that door's open
that door is closed and let's say you
have a gun in the kitchen you have a gun
what rights do you have to protect your
home at that time
the the bottom line it's it's called a
state of mind shooting
as long as you feel your life
is in imminent danger you have the right
to do anything you want to to protect
yourself now
you don't have the right
if you think oh some son of a [ __ ] is
in my house now i'm gonna go track that
[ __ ] down and shoot him
you can't do that
he ha you have to be able to articulate
whatever you talk to the cop whenever
you talk to anybody as long as you feel
that your life or the life of someone
else is an imminent danger you have the
right to take action
so if you come home and there's somebody
in the other side of your house
do you go back into the garage leave
your house
call the police what i i i would
definitely call the police right away
before i go inside because i don't know
what he has i don't know anything
tactically first thing i do is step back
be a good witness let him get away out
the back door and jump fences if he
wants to but i know by stepping back i'm
not going to lose my life
and i know the cops are going to be on
their way there's assistance
and and george something that i hadn't
done in a long time but i'm doing now on
a regular basis i'm packing it
everywhere now
you know i i do so
if i come in my garage in my house i'm
packing but i'm not gonna take somebody
on like that just like you said i'd back
out
be a good witness call the cops let them
come down let them take care as long as
nobody's
but do you have a license to carry
oh yeah
yes
um what if you shoot somebody and you
don't have a license to carry
you know it
it's a misdemeanor to carry without a
license and you know
and if you take somebody's life well
then all you have to do is worry about
civil civil liability
and not so much criminality if you're
justified in shooting whether you have a
license or not
if you don't have a license to carry and
you shoot somebody and kill them and
they were in the commission of a felony
or they're about to kill you you still
have the right to self-defense
you were wrong for having a gun without
but that's could be a misdemeanor charge
but if you're driving around and you
have
a gun under your seat
and somebody tries to or somebody
comes at you let's say you're pumping
gas
and you turn around there's a guy there
and he looks like he's like hey man
what's up hey what's going on and then
he's like you just see this
and you say you know let me have your
wallet or whatever and you go let me get
it and now you grab your gun
and maybe you have a wallet in this hand
and then you can you fire on that dude
if you think that if you that guy's
about to harm you it says the commission
of a robbery which is a felony if you
think your life is in danger
yeah just started i thought the guy was
going to kill me whether i gave my
wallet or not
you know and i'm not advocating shooting
everybody but i'm saying as long as the
key is the ability to
articulate the fact that you thought
your life was in danger
but i think most people think that like
most
[ __ ] viejos like me like
first of all i can't run away i might as
well [ __ ] just laid out
the the um
but it's not like they you're shooting
somebody on a tv show like it's it's
real life i mean you were in vietnam
real life it's way [ __ ] different man
yeah
i just showed i did a show i told her
about it i didn't want her to see it uh
a friend of mine sent me a video
and it's a guy committing a robbery i
don't know if it's inside
a business offer a bank the guy's
sitting down sitting down all of a
sudden
he gets up and he's armed and there's a
security guard there which makes me
think it's some kind of financial
institution
and he runs right at the security guy
gun pointed at him
and he starts shooting the security
guard pulls a gun and shoots him
hits the guy the suspect
right in the neck
blood starts coming out like you turn
the faucet on churros all over the place
and he's still shooting he's still going
from the time he gets shot i put my
stopwatch on him
he runs after the security guard
shooting at him but now the security
guard said oh [ __ ] he's right he drops
his gun
he's ducking and get out of the way and
you can just see blood squirting out of
this guy around
37 seconds
from the time he got hit
till the time he's down on the ground no
longer
and all that time that's 37 so you think
about how long 30 and that guy got hit
in the carotid artery
how long you know you just
he broke an oil line and burnt burned up
about he's still fi yeah he's still
firing thirty seven seconds still had
priority
yeah so that's what you have to deal
with it's not like on tv some shots head
shots knock you down automatic you know
they put you down
some shots will put you down but it
doesn't mean right here
that was blood you're losing that didn't
put him down but he only had about 30
seconds to live
what about uh
what about that mma fighter kane
velazquez that
is in san jose
in uh in jail because
he had somebody in his family that was
sexually abused by someone and he chased
a dude down
and i think he might have killed a dude
and he's in jail
yeah it's just is that just can he go
is it murder
yeah it is
it it's it's not in the right he's not
defending himself
he's no longer saving somebody else he
has the right to stop him
because that guy is committed a felony
and he has the right to stop him and
hold him for cops
but depending on this and i don't know
any of the circumstances
but just to stop him and beat the dog
[ __ ] out of the war the fact now he's
dead
unfortunately
that's a that's a murder probably drop
down to a manslaughter right but you're
going away
yeah
because even though it's uh you know
it's
deemed you know you're for somebody but
it's just still
you're still breaking the law yeah he
chased the guy down i think he shot at
his car
might have hit him killed him and then
he's
yeah but they know people have a lot of
your own jerks like free free kane but
no he committed i mean they're not going
to let him go like hey you know hey you
were
you reduced to crying admirable you were
trying to be the passion yeah
but it's still going to be
at minimal a manslaughter
that's better to murder
yeah
all right well you know i think by the
time we we meet again i might i might
actually be back we might be back in the
studio
oh good
yeah good i i can't wait to see i'll be
with you again but i think that um
covet is still covert is still out there
yeah so i think people need to be safe
again because uh
you know i can't say too much but
allegedly there are some people around
me that
uh have had it
and um
you know i think we all need to be safe
tell me i'll put my calzones around here
as a map if you want right there hey go
to dodger stadium
uh
eat before you go
finally my finally my grandparents are
right
uh
but uh
i hope that everything gets resolved and
i hope that
any worker wanting to stand up for his
or her rights
be heard and
yeah everything's about the bottom line
but also
you can't run a business without
those people
that's right that's right we need them
and uh
yeah
somebody's leaving somebody sharp time
to bring it up
a week before the all-star game
you talk about pressure that'll do it
let's see what happens because uh
i mean if you're gonna have close to 60
000 people in there you can't have
novices behind the
the counter trying to get you something
to drink not only that they'll be
ripping you off brother
yeah
yeah
all right man uh
you know we did a more serious one today
yeah yeah uh but that's all right
and uh
i hope that the next time we we do this
we'll do it in person
oh that is
aaron
aaron oh yeah i'm almost done here man i
think i'm done at the end of the week
all right all right dudes
all right see when you get back george
all right right on
you